well good evening everyone
we're in brussels at a pivotal time
stability in europe
hangs in the balance
and the international rules based order
that's critical to maintaining peace
and security
is being put to the test by russia's
unprovoked and unjustified invasion of
ukraine
the kremlin's attacks are inflicting an
ever increasing toll on civilians there
hundreds if not thousands of ukrainians
have been killed
many more wounded
as have citizens of other countries
more than a million refugees have fled
ukraine to neighboring countries
millions of people across ukraine
are trapped in increasingly dire
conditions
as russia destroys more critical
infrastructure
for example mario paul's mayor says that
most of the besieged cities residents
are living without water
without electricity without heat
bridges to the city have been destroyed
women children
growing ranks of wounded civilians
cannot get out food and medical supplies
cannot get in
the mayor wrote today and i quote
we are simply being destroyed
the world has seen russia used these
grisly tactics before
in syria
and chechnya
meanwhile
russia's reckless operation
around the zapariza nuclear power plant
risked a catastrophe a nuclear incident
the kremlin should immediately cease all
attacks around ukrainian nuclear
facilities and allow civilian personnel
to do their work to ensure the
facility's safety and security as both
the iaea director general and a
resolution adopted yesterday by the
agency's board of governors have called
on russia to do
the ukrainian people and government
continue to show remarkable courage in
defending their country defending their
freedom
defending one another
we said that if president putin invaded
ukraine we would increase our support
for ukraine's ability to defend itself
while imposing swoosh and severe costs
on the kremlin
that's exactly what the united states
and our allies and partners are doing
that was the focus of our ministerial
meetings today uh with nato allies with
the g7 with the european union as well
as in my discussions with nato secretary
general uh with uh the eu commission
president van der lyon
with the eu council president michelle
we want our alliances to be strong
enough to meet any threat
that's why from day one president biden
made reinvigorating re-energizing our
alliances and partnerships the
foundation of our foreign policy
it's why as secretary of state
i've come to brussels home to nato and
the eu more than to any other world
capital
and that's why we invested so much
effort in finding
new ways and coalitions to bring allies
and partners together
now we're seeing why that work matters
at nato uh we were joined by the
ministers of finland and sweden of the
eu high representative joseph burrell
the foreign ministers of ukraine the
united kingdom and canada as well as the
secretary general stoltenberg also took
part in our meeting with the eu
never before have nato and the european
union and other partner nations worked
so closely together
this is a new kind of cooperation
and
will bring this to bear
not just in this crisis but
in the in the years to come
and our european allies and partners are
stepping up
to lead in unprecedented ways
for the first time nato has activated
and deployed parts of its response force
several nato allies including the uk
germany netherlands denmark spain france
has sent troops and aircraft and ships
to reinforce the alliance's eastern
flank every nato allies providing either
military humanitarian aid to ukraine
most are providing both
for the first time
the european union is financing the
purchase and delivery of military
assistance to a country under attack the
bloc swiftly adopted the biggest
sanctions package in history against
russia
and the eu is granted immediate refuge
to ukrainians and others who call
ukraine home the first time it has
invoked this protection mechanism
individual countries are also taking
extraordinary steps
germany is doubling its defense spending
poland has opened its arms to more than
half a million ukrainian refugees
switzerland set aside its traditional
neutrality to adopt the european union's
sanctions on russia the list goes on
these and other efforts by our european
allies to deepen their own capabilities
and cooperation
do not undermine the transatlantic
security alliance they deepen our
collected might
as recently as a few weeks ago
some questioned whether
if the regional or international rules
based order came under threat
whether our european allies and partners
would be willing to shoulder their fair
share of the burden the risk the cost to
defend it
in the last nine days european countries
have demonstrated they are more than
ready to stand up
and stand together
and the united states is standing with
europe pursuing complementary actions
and policies in close coordination with
our allies and partners
to give just a few examples
we've deployed an additional seven
thousand troops to europe and
repositioned our forces already on the
continent to strengthen nato's eastern
flank we continue to type our severe
economic sanctions on russia
last night as i think you know we
extended temporary protective status
to tens of thousands of ukrainians
living in the united states
and the president has requested an
additional 10 billion dollars from
congress
to deliver more humanitarian security
and economic assistance in ukraine and
the surrounding region over the coming
days and weeks
yesterday
president putin said his so-called
special military operation
is proceeding exactly as planned
well it's hard to imagine that his plan
included inspiring the ukrainian people
to defend their country with such
tenacity
strengthening the resolve and solidarity
of nato in the eu
uniting the world in opposition to
moscow including 141 countries at the
united nations an unprecedented number
of international businesses associations
cultural institutions that have cut ties
with russia
causing the russian economy to go into
free fall
motivating tens of thousands of russians
to protest and countless more to leave
the country
and increasingly turning russia into a
pariah state
if that was president putin's plan well
you can say it's working
russia has never been so isolated
we have never been more united
but
let me reiterate one thing because it's
very important
we take these actions not because
we oppose the russian people we do not
we regret that tens of millions of
russians will suffer because of the
dangerous decisions made by a tiny
circle of corrupt leaders in their
cronies who've consistently put their
interests
above those of the russian people
who are doing everything they can to
hide their war of choice from the
russian public
today's discussion with nato the eu the
g7 affirmed that we're fully aligned on
our goals
and our determination to meet them
we'll deepen our support for ukraine's
brave defenders and for the ukrainian
civilians suffering as a result of the
deepening humanitarian crisis
we'll continue to raise the cost for
president putin and all who carry out
and enable his war of choice and the
devastation that it's causing
we'll continue to strengthen our
capacity to defend our collective
security and deter further escalation by
russia including by upholding our
article 5 commitment that an attack on
one is an attack on all
nato is a defensive alliance we've never
sought and will not seek conflict with
russia
but as president biden has said
we will defend every inch of nato
territory no one should doubt america's
readiness or our resolve
at the same time we'll keep open the
door to dialogue and diplomacy
while making clear to the kremlin that
unless it changes course it will
continue down the road of increasing
isolation and economic pain
and will support ukraine and its talks
with russia to reach a ceasefire and the
unconditional withdrawal of russian
forces something that foreign minister
khalifa and i have been discussing on a
daily basis
in the meantime
we're working urgently with the
government of ukraine the icrc and
others to create humanitarian corridors
that will allow civilians to get out of
ukraine's besieged cities and to allow
food medicine and other vital supplies
to get in
russia's attack created this
humanitarian crisis
now all countries have a responsibility
to pressure the kremlin to alleviate at
least some of the misery that it has
wrought
of all the consequences of moscow's
unprovoked attack one of the most
unexpected is the spark it is lit in
people around the world
who've come out to demonstrate for
freedom for the rights of ukrainians
that includes valiant individuals in
places where protesting the kremlin's
war means risking arrest beatings are
worse
as thousands of russians and yellow
russians have done
for years we've seen the dangerous tide
rolling back democracy and human rights
and undercutting the rules based order
fueled in no small part by moscow
with this brutal invasion
we
our european allies and partners and
people everywhere
are being reminded of just how much is
at stake
now
we see the tide of democracy rising
to the moment
with that i'm happy to take some
questions
hi mr secretary paul um
you've the the west has put
unprecedented sanctions on russia very
punishing
uh yet it doesn't seem to have slowed uh
the russian military's advance on
ukraine uh today nato seemed to forswear
absolutely
uh putting in a no-fly zone that might
protect the ukrainians
given that nothing seems to have slowed
this invasion what can you tell the
ukrainian people who only see things
getting worse seeing a disaster seeing
more suffering and are pleading for more
help from the west and i
have a little follow-up i could ask it
now or in a moment no go ahead please um
the west nato has been involved in this
in terms of supplying a lot of arms
which you've mentioned
uh to ukraine
can't it supply more
uh more
uh
more effective arms larger weapons jets
has been taught have been talked about
nato is engaged in this can't it do more
for
ukraine
thank you let me take the second part uh
uh first uh
we're in
constant contact with uh with ukraine
we've got with uh government officials
and leaders on
on their needs uh and in constant
contact and coordination with allies and
partners on providing for those needs
when it comes to uh security uh
assistance
um
we've already been engaged in in a
remarkable effort just speaking for the
united states
uh with the various drawdowns that
president biden has done
we've provided over the past
year and change
more than a billion dollars in security
assistance to ukraine the most recent
drawdown
that
was issued by the president
of 350 million dollars we have already
uh
sent into ukraine uh about 250 million
dollars worth of that uh that drawdown
so this is happening every single day
and uh you're seeing
the uh
means that uh ukraine needs to defend
itself get into the hands of ukrainians
who are doing that
uh having said that
one of the things that we talked about
at length today in our various meetings
at uh nato and the eu
was um
what more we can do and uh and how to do
it effectively
i would add that i think as you know uh
foreign minister kalaiba actually
came into our meetings by video we heard
from him
directly some of the additional things
that ukraine is looking for we're
working on all of that uh every every
single day
we're also
a weak and change in
to this horrific uh war wrought by uh by
russia
uh
the we've had already
a dramatic impact far beyond i think
what anyone would have expected on
russia and its economy
the ruble is trading at its weakest
levels ever it's worth less than a penny
russian authorities are expecting
exporters to sell
at least 80 percent of the currency
they have to prop up what is a rapidly
uh weakening currency the stock market's
been closed for days
due to a fear of capital flight once it
opens uh this is the longest stretch of
emergency closure since russia defaulted
back in
the 1990s
the cbr has more than doubled their key
interest rate central bank to 20
the highest in almost 20 years
capital controls et cetera we're seeing
i have a
list five pages long
all the businesses that have left
russia
but
this take the impact is is there it's
powerful it's real and it is building so
let's see uh how russia responds to that
as
uh this really takes hold and takes your
grip um
second
as we've been demonstrating by
not only what we've been saying but what
we've been doing
the support for ukraine
is
real profound extensive the security
assistance that we just talked about
that continues to go in the humanitarian
support that we continue to build in
response to uh the uh humanitarian uh
horror that russia has brought uh as
well as economic assistance
unfortunately this is not like flipping
a light switch
it takes time and when you have an uh in
the case of russia and president putin
is russia
a country that is uh prepared to go to
uh excessive
uh means to uh achieve its results
um it's uh it is a real challenge but
not only are we at it every day i think
what the ukrainian people can see
is
virtually the entire world united in
support of them in support of their
cause of independence territorial
integrity freedom
uh demonstrated by the meetings we had
today demonstrated by the 141 countries
that came together at the united nations
uh to make that clear
so there is a
huge tide of support for ukraine there
is a huge weight bearing down on russia
let's see what the impact is mcmahon
hero news
hi there thank you so much for the floor
mate mcmahon your news so we heard this
morning at nato that the situation will
get worse before it gets better
so tell us what do you know that we
don't
and is the no to the no-fly zone to set
in stone completely or would you
consider it if this conflict does become
a massacre just to follow was it naive
of you and of course the europeans to
trust and couldn't offer diplomacy thank
you so much
um
when we say it uh is likely to to get
worse it's um
unfortunately based on everything we
know about uh
president putin's methods when it comes
to uh seeking to
subjugate
another country to uh to his will uh or
another region too as well we saw it in
chechnya
we've seen it in syria
uh we saw it of course in in 2014
in uh in ukraine
and
what we're seeing on the uh
on the battlefield is
russian forces seeking to encircle the
major cities including kiev and we're
seeing them use increasingly
brutal methods
including going at um at civilians and
civilian populations so
i think
the the
terrible expectation is that um
the suffering we've already seen is
is likely to get worse before it gets
better uh for for as long as
uh russia pursues these methods
uh so
that is uh unfortunately
more likely than not although we're
doing uh everything we can to try to
move us to a different track
um
with regard to uh
the no-fly zone i think uh
you heard
native secretary john stoltenberg speak
to this
uh earlier today one of the
responsibilities we have even as we are
uh
doing everything we can to
give the ukrainian people the means to
defend themselves uh effectively against
russia we also have a responsibility as
the secretary general said
to ensure that the war doesn't
spill over even beyond ukraine
uh and
again uh because i think he he put it so
well as he as he noted uh the only way
to actually implement something like a
no-fly zone uh is to send nato planes
into ukrainian airspace and to shoot
down russian planes that
could lead to a full-fledged war
in europe president has been clear
that we
are not going to get into a war with
russia
but
we are
going to
tremendous lengths with allies and
partners
to
provide ukrainians with the means to uh
to effectively defend themselves and of
course we're seeing every single day
their extraordinary heroism
as well as um
very uh very real results in um in what
they're doing to
to achieve that
and i'm sorry i missed the last part of
your your question
just
do you feel like because i remember we
spoke together uh last spring when you
were here in brussels at the nato
headquarters and i feel the question now
is do you feel that you were naive or
the europeans were naive to trust in
putin that he would come to the table
and he would choose diplomacy over this
invasion well i'll only speak for i'll
only speak for
the united states i think we were the
opposite of naive
we have been saying
warning
uh for months
that uh
president putin was was planning
and was likely to carry out an
aggression
of ukraine
and uh i and of course
uh in recent weeks before the invasion
began
i laid out before the united nations the
security council exactly what we
expected putin to do
and how he would do it creating
a bogus pretext for uh for war
and then
using those
false flags and other operations as
justification for invading ukraine
and for
months we made clear that this is what
we expected but at the same time
it's our obligation
my obligation the obligation of
allies and partners to pursue diplomacy
if there is any opportunity to do so
because as we said all along it's far
preferable
than what we're seeing and again as we
said all along
uh there are two paths that russia can
take one is diplomacy and dialogue the
other is aggression against ukraine and
we said we would be prepared either way
and we are
nomi
bbc
thank you secretary um are you
considering any sanctions against russia
because realistically
how can the west defeat
putin in ukraine when the west also pays
putin up to 700 million dollars a day
in oil
gas and coal i know the british foreign
minister this trust has talked about it
how britain's looking into it are you
first as a general proposition uh
nothing is off the table and we are
evaluating every single day
uh
the sanctions
their implementation and additional
measures
the sanctions are designed in the first
instance of course to have maximum
impact on russia
and putin while minimizing harm to us
and our allies and partners
um
there's no
strategic interest in reducing the the
global supply of energy
the immediate effect would be to raise
prices at the pump for americans and
also to have
russian profits with
rising prices um
so we've been carving out payments for
energy trade and transport from the
sanctions that we've been involving
but we have a strong interest we and our
allies integrating russia's status as a
leading energy supplier
over time this would be a profound
strategic shift that's why nordstrom 2
was shut down
that's why we're surging
lng to europe right now to help
accelerate its diversification
away from russian gas it's why we're
denying critical technologies to russia
for further energy exploration going
forward through the export controls we
put in place this is part of a process
to
reduce reliance
dependence on russian energy
so that's where our focus is but again
as i said we're looking at these things
every single day
how long will that take
well how many people have to die in
ukraine i'm not going to put a time
frame on it what what's happened in
record time
uh as we've seen
are sanctions and other measures that a
few weeks ago people would have said
we're never going to happen
i think we've demonstrated very very
clearly
uh that what we said we would do
many months ago when this
crisis first began to to emerge
back in in november december
um
the g7 countries the european union
i said that if russia chose the path of
aggression we would impose massive
consequences on russia including
unprecedented economic sanctions
i know some some people thought uh that
that was more uh rhetoric than reality i
think we've demonstrated already
uh how strong that reality is and again
we're looking every day
at
measures to increase
the extraordinary pressure we're already
exerting we'll take a final question
thank you very much the secretary i have
two questions first is also on no-fly
zone you said that uh
nato will not send
fighter jets to ukraine to shut down
russians it's understandable but there
is another way to impose this no-fly
zone and i mean send into ukraine air
defense capabilities of course united
states sent uh stinger missiles but i'm
speaking about high to medium air
defense capabilities to support the
currently uh working ukrainian defense
capabilities with s 300 and book which
are working also quite well the second
question is you saw we saw
more than a week of fighting and how
russian forces
weren't able to
achieve
most of its objectives they were bogged
down they were stopped in many places so
how does this week of
war change the u.s assessment of the
might of russian
military that was considered to be quite
high now what is your assessment now
thank you very much thank you um
first part of the question
we are looking every day at what
technologies what capacities we can
effectively deliver to uh to ukraine
to uh to defend itself and that's an
ongoing conversation uh literally
happening on a daily basis both with uh
with ukraine and government officials as
well as among
allies and partners and
so
the main
focus is on making sure that
anything
we provide can be
used uh used effectively
uh and uh and in a timely way
so uh but as i said that's quite
literally something we're looking at
every um every day
so
i don't want to draw any uh conclusions
from uh
the week of uh
of invasion uh in terms of what this
tells us about um
about russia or its capabilities i think
we'll
we'll have time to uh to fully assess
that
what we do know what it does tell us
is
how
extraordinary
uh the ukrainian people are
their will
their determination
their
absolute
commitment
to defend their country to defend their
freedom to defend their future that's
the story of the past week
and it's an incredibly powerful one
thank you thank you very much
uh
my
yes
okay
okay
you